foreign
people from the 32 countries
participating in the World Cup gathered
in oxygen Park in Doha for the
generation amazing Festival it's the
culmination of a year-long Exchange
program in the run-up to the World Cup I
come here in representation of my whole
country so I believe it's a great
opportunity for me to get to know more
people and all the values that are going
to be instilled in me after this whole
event so once I go back to Argentina I
want to spread all my knowledge that I
get here
FIFA president Johnny Infantino who's a
supporter of generation amazing was at
the opening ceremony the program already
has a decade of work to its name
organizers say its Legacy will continue
beyond the Qatar World Cup our aim 10
years ago was to empower disadvantaged
lives of one million people that was the
target one million young lives and
through our football for development
programs and methodology that we've
created we've been able to provide safe
spaces in over 30 countries we've built
football pitches over 40 football
pitches in these 30 countries and then
you know we've reached our Target of
reaching 1 million beneficiaries in
August this year
some of football's biggest names were on
hand to spread the message and share
their expertise including former England
Captain David Beckham I want to say to
all of you today is your day to dream
[Applause]
participants will spend a week in Doha
attending workshops meeting football
players and watching World Cup matches
it's hoped this experience will Empower
young people with the skills needed to
promote sustainable development in their
communities the start of the World Cup
is just days away now and the tournament
itself less less than a month but
organizers here hope its benefits will
last four years to come Victoria gatenby
Al Jazeera Doha